all right we're back uh let's do it
let's have the conversation Israel
Palestine um it's been a little more
than two weeks since the terrorist
attack by Hamas October 7th and um I
know a lot of people reaching out and
they're like hey when are you going to
talk about this when are you going to
talk about this I learned something in
the Russia Ukraine War uh and uh it
confirmed this quote that exists this
quote is uh when the war starts the
truth dies and I remember at the
beginning of the Russia Ukraine war
there's that great story of the uh the
ghost of Kiev and I got like emotional
watching videos about it like I remember
almost tearing up about this man that
gets in his plane after not serving in
the military for 20 years and he hits
the guys he starts taking out these
Russian Jets and the News was covering
it every Instagram was covering there's
YouTube stories about it and then a week
later it turns out it's not true and I
think that we've learned that uh you
know when the war starts the truth ends
up dying at least on our social feeds
over the last few weeks and the reason
why I didn't kneejerk jump to you know
saying hey let's let's talk about this
and give our opinion and stay at one
we're obviously [__] comedians we're
not going to solve a geopolitical crisis
been going on for 70 [__] years but
also because we're reacting emotionally
to these things that we don't know
exactly if they're true or not right
like and I mean you saw it you even see
it with the hospital bombing like we to
this day still don't know exactly what
the [__] happened yeah you know both
sides are obviously claiming the other
side both sides are obviously using tons
of propaganda to support their positions
and I think that what a lot of people
are going through over the last couple
weeks uh especially people who are like
one um one one one bit removed from it
like obviously if you're Israeli or
you're Jewish you're locked in your
passionate if you're Palestinian you're
locked in your passionate but those of
us who aren't either I think what we've
been going through is just like what the
[__] is true yeah what the [__] is going
on like I'm getting all this information
on my feet and I'm reacting to it and
then I'm finding out two hours later oh
that was actually a picture from Kosovo
and you're like what what is what is
happening
here and uh I think I think it took some
time and I just want to like talk to
some Jewish friends I want to talk to
some Palestinian friends I just want to
understand what both uh groups were
feeling and um I understand now how
unbelievably isolating it is to be both
of them in this scenario so like let's
just take for example the Jews right
you're a western Jew you raised your
entire life with the with history with
the stories of your victimization and
your oppression right Jews been kicked
out of every single [__] country
they've ever been in I mean like
literally you go to a country even on
this this tour I'd be doing some
research of the city we're in and then I
just come across the date that the Jews
were kicked out and I was like oh [__]
King George did it to the [__] Jews
in year 1000 or whatever in England I
didn't even know that happened like
every single country so you're you're
listening to this information you're as
a western Jew you're hearing about it um
your grandparents you private
grandparents the Holocaust tells you
about it people are going to try to
exterminate us 100% they're telling you
this constantly they're tell hey you're
different and just let you know it could
happen again we got to be very careful
you got to be on your p's and q's and
you're a western Jew that grows up in
[__] New York you grow up in LA or
something you're like I'm just American
I'm like a white kid from America what
are they talking about you hear about
the anti-Semitism that will pop up
sometimes but you're like I'm American
is this is my parents that was like my
parents'
time and then October 7th happens um
disgusting Act of Terror from Hamas
terrorist
organization um in uh in Gaza and kills
over a thousand Jews and you think the
reaction is going to be empathy and
sympathy and concern for you and what
your people just went through this
disgusting act but all of a sudden you
see the next day there are like people
in the streets seemingly like excited
about it and their sections is not
everybody but there are people that are
like chanting horribly anti-semitic
things yeah truly anti-semitic things
100% And that's not everybody of course
but there there are documented section
sections of the people that were doing
enough that it confirms all the sudden
that voice that you quieted your whole
life because you're like that's just my
grandparents being crazy you're like
holy [__] is it true this is a worst
case scenario we are different they are
out for us they do hate us and they hate
us because we're Jewish that's the
conclusion that you would logically come
to they want to external us they want us
gone right you hear these
chants so I understand what a Jewish
person feels like in that moment
especially a western Jewish person who
is somewhat removed from the conflict
obviously everybody there has family
members family members who have lost
their lives you're aware of it but
you're living in the west right and you
hear this thing and you're like oh my
God it is true it is true we are
different and people are out to get us
[__] when we were in [__] uh
Amsterdam tell the story you guys are
walking around at night yeah walking
down the street and then this dude like
comes out to Dove and he's like hammered
walking through the streets of Amsterdam
he just seemed like a regular dude he
was like fist bumping everyone like
being all fun and he looks at Dove and
he's like oh where where are you from
and Dove was like oh Moroccan he's like
are you Jewish and he's like yeah I'm a
Moroccan Jew and he goes oh what do you
think about what's going on and like
gets in his face and like starts to like
size him up and Dove Lally is just like
look peace for everyone we just want
everyone to be happy we love everyone
and he goes yeah we don't [__] with is
Israel around here we we don't [__] with
Jews around here your kind isn't welcome
here kind isn't welcome here is where it
gets like oh now it's hate and then we
all step in we're like bro chill what
are you doing the guy's like hammered he
[__] in a blackout he's like the
typical Jew he always run like you
always get other people to fight your
battles typical Jew blah blah blah and
then that was it I'd never seen
anti-Semitism like out in the open yeah
just walking down the street and am it
yeah you see you hear about it on
[__] Call of Duty you know you see it
on comments but you never seen like the
actual like hate and
vital and you could see how [__]
isolating that must be if you're Jewish
in that moment where you're expecting
the sympathy and empathy of the world
for losing over a thousand innocent
people we're not talking about like two
armies colliding we're talking about
innocent people that have died like
innocent people should never bear the
cost of this ever still hostages and
stuff still hostages to this day and
then you don't feel you're like oh my
God I'm [__] isolated and not only
are they not giving you sympathy some
people are celebrating oh exactly and
that's when I was reaching out to my
Jewish friends I was like oh I I don't
ever think I've acknowledged that
anti-Semitism is a thing still because I
think we see it like n you're white yeah
it's not like that for a sizable
percentage of human beings not a
majority but enough that it's
significant and also in like you often
see Jews and you're like oh they're
doing well they're making money they'll
be all right it's like you guys are like
well you guys are doing well but it's
like it's like yeah we we go through
racism too but we're also struggling you
know what I mean like so I don't think
there is the same sympathy or empathy
given to to Jews like here in the west
is like they'll call out anti-Semitism
for it's like oh they own the banks or
whatever yeah you're like give me
that how do I get that oppressed so I
understand that right and then you look
at the Palestinian side and I can also
see how
unbelievably isolated they isolating it
is for them where the only time they're
ever talked about and their plight is
ever discussed is when they're the
terrorist yeah so imagine how
infuriating that is where every single
day you're living I guess in an open air
prison in Gaza every single day there's
an occupation there are it's not this is
not the first time builds have been
bombed this is not the first time there
have been Palestinians killed nobody's
talking about it now they're talking
about and they're talking about you guys
as terrorists and rightfully Hamas
absolutely terrorist disgusting act
nothing justifies it nothing that
happened before justify what happened to
those innocent people in Israel okay um
and an Israeli kid that's 8 years old
doesn't know what the [__] Word
occupation even means there's no way you
can justify the murdering of them right
but I can understand why these
Palestinians are like the only time the
media in the west ever talks about us is
when we're ter generous and what about
our innocent people who got killed what
about our innocent people you don't ever
mention that M what about our innocent
kids yeah yeah you know what about what
we go through on an everyday basis why
are do we not have humanitarian concerns
for us at all where the [__] is it
where's the attention where's the
concern it feels like nobody cares about
you that same feeling that the Jews felt
on October 7th nobody cares about us
they're feeling that nobody cares about
us and then when something does happen
when Hamas is this disgusting Act of
Terror not only does nobody care about
us now we're going to label you all as
terrorists so we're already view they're
already like Hey we're victims here now
not only are we not victims you stripped
our victimhood we're the oppressors yeah
while we're being oppressed we're
getting pushed off our land and then one
action makes us oppressors and
terrorists this has been going on for
decades you guys haven't and done
anything and when I saw this and I'm
talking to my Palestinian friend I'm
talking to my my Jewish friends I've
realized there's this like gigantic
Chasm that exists with this issue first
of all the casuals the people who are
not involved in it right let's say the
us we are still trying to figure out
what the history of this is for the last
70 the average person doesn't even know
they hear these Buzz settlements I'm the
Aver person occation they don't get
along they can't have a two State like
yeah that's literally what it is right
and then the people that are involved
every one of them has a cousin who died
a brother who died a family member who
was [__] died so they are locked in
right and I see this CM I'm like I have
to understand like what both sides are
are feeling but most importantly like
what they're feeling about specific
things and the distance between both
sides is so far you would think there
are two different conflicts yeah like if
you speak to an Israeli or a Jew about
this and you speak to a Palestinian You'
be like there's no way you guys are
speaking about the same comp if you open
your social media it looks like two
different complet y because like for
example there's the word that you see
thrown around all the time Zionism
Zionism this this idea this concept that
there should be a Jewish state right
Zionist is used as a Prive if you're
Palestinian calling someone a Zionist
that is a negative word like you say are
you a Zionist right if you ask a Jewish
person if they're a Zionist they're just
interpreting that as do I believe that
Israel should exist well yeah of course
I believe Israel should exist but what
does the state of Israel mean to a
Palestinian it means you're pushing me
off my land you're going to keep taking
away my it stands for the oppression
stands for the occupation right it's
like it's like asking it's like I I I'm
a patri I love
America a Native American has a
different interpretation of my
patriotism my patriotism represents the
eradication of their people and the
removal of them from their land so if a
Native American asks me are you a
patriot I go hell yeah [__] love
America they're like how could you love
America you're a terrorist to them I'm
exactly as a black man if I hear make
America great again I was like wait how
far back you know what you talking about
literally that 100% And to them a lot of
them it means hey used to have
manufacturing jobs my parents used to
have a job that's the America I'm
thinking about when I think make America
great again I'm not thinking about you
guys being subjugated but obviously
that's all yall are but how could you
not think exactly so it's even the
support the troops Thing Mark mhm like
break down that example that you had
about the like as an American we're like
yeah we support our troops what does
that mean to the places that our troops
are at yeah bomb the wedding that my
uncle was at all right those are the
troops you support you're like well
that's not what I thought when you asked
me to support the troops support the
risking their my brother-in-law that's
in the Navy I support him yeah so this
the words that are a sense of Pride for
one side or the source of Oppression for
another how can they even begin to have
a conversation about what's going on if
they can't even agree on the definition
of the word and both of them are
understandably right about it right so
so far apart once I'm seeing like how
far this Chasm is I'm like what else is
going going on here and I'm like okay
the problem it seems like everybody's
talking about currently right now is
Hamas how do we get Hamas out of Gaza
because if we could get Hamas out of
Gaza then Gaza could live free and
everything would be good it's it's
hamas's terrorist organization that's
subjugating their people and every
Palestinian I've ever spoken to is like
yes Hamas is horrible horrible
disgusting absolutely disgusting what
they did and that terror attack is
discussing what they've done before and
it's disgusting how they've oppressed us
within Gaza right every single person
I've ever spoken to just like every
single Jew I've ever spok to is like
yeah we want a two-state solution we
want them to be able to live free we
want to be able to live free we don't
want this at all every single um jsh
person I was spoken to is like we don't
even want the settlements why are we
keeping do the settlements you're just
aggravating this [__] situation these
people on both sides don't like the
Israeli government either bro there was
huge [__] uh like there was like
riots and there was these huge protests
in Israel before up to for like six
months up to October 6 about how divided
the country was about you know I went to
I went to Israel with Weezy and almost
everyone we spoke too like and younger
kids around our age it's like all don't
like the government what exactly exactly
and I think it's probably no different
for like American intervention
strategies where it's like I don't think
that's representative of American
sentiment like I don't think if you ask
the average American like yeah we should
[__] be in Afghanistan for 25 years
that's what we need we're like no we're
like so far removed from it yeah but if
you're an Afghanistan if you're a person
from Afghanistan if you're afani Afghan
you're if you're an Afghan you're like
how could I separate you from your
government how how can I like it's your
government that's doing this to me and
you vote them in right isn't it a
democracy CL ignorance [__] you you're
taking my rights you're killing my
family members and you're somehow
removed from that no [__] you you vote
these people in yeah and then I mean and
there was this guy basam YF that was on
Pierce Morgan he had this interview and
he brought up an interesting point he's
like people bring up this thing about
Hamas all the time Hamas is the issue
and he goes there's no Hamas in the West
Bank and Israel continues to occupied
there's a apartheid state and they
continue to expand these settlements you
can't tell me he he's basically say what
is the excuse for that H like what why
why isn't there this dreamlike scenario
over in the West Bank if there's no
Hamas if Hamas is the only issue and I
understand that frustration as well I
understand that frustration for the
Palestinian PE people who are like
hey yeah let's agree let's get Hamas out
of here but where is the good faith show
us the good faith that it will be
different how can I believe if your
right now you're like how can I believe
it's going to be a different scenario
than the West Bank if we have the
scenario without Hamas and there's still
people that are living and struggling
under the occupation I get that
frustration Israel needs to to show that
proof that with the scenario without
Hamas is it better of course but are
they still living is it still occupied
is it still an apartheid state yeah they
need to prove that they're the ones in
control they're the ones in charge I
think it's their burden of proof yeah
don't you think mhm yeah but yeah I
don't think we're here necessarily to
offer a solution but just to empathize
with the both sides that are yeah
there's no way we could the biggest
thing that's lacking across the board I
think if both and not geopolitically but
person to person if both sides just
acknowledge yeah man what happened to
you is [__] up I think they would be
way more receptive to hearing the other
side if Palestinians are like hey man I
understand a lot of people are
anti-semitic and that probably sucks and
historically you have been oppressed
that sucks then I think Israel be like
yeah also what's been happening to you
guys doesn't justify the terror attack
but you were oppressed for decades you
know in your own Homeland and that's
[__] I think yeah it's just so hard I
imagine for both sides to even begin to
offer the Olive Branch when you feel
like you're being stepped on you know
it's
like yeah it's just it's look again like
you said we're not here to offer
solution but we are here to offer that
observation that there is this gigantic
Chasm between both sides and even how
there interpreting the
same um not only events but reaction to
those events MH you know like I I can I
can can't even imagine the
frustration you must feel if you're
Palestinian and there's not a peep about
anything you're going through until your
side commits an act of Terror and I
cannot even imagine the frustration of
Jews that inocent Jews a thousand of
them are [__] murdered and there are
people in the streets seemingly like
supportive of it really some crazy
things [__] yeah and we're not even
bringing in like the geopolitical chess
moves that are being made outside of
their situation how this is really a
proxy in a lot of ways for what other
countries are trying to either stop or
how other countries are trying to bring
attention away from certain things like
Russia has everything to gain from
America putting money into this struggle
from America bringing warships into this
struggle you know what happens if we
start pulling money away from Ukraine
and that's support then Russia takes
that immediately so if I'm Russia I want
to bolster this as much as I possibly
can fan that flame if you're Iran Iran
Saudi Arabia and Israel were about to
sign a deal that they were going to be
friends publicly first time I think in
history if I'm Iran I'm like I can't let
that happen I got to do something right
here I have to support something that's
going to make Israel behave in a way
that's going to make Saudi Arabia not
able publicly to sign some sort of
agreement or Accords with them because
they have to save face mhm it's yeah and
like most wars rich and powerful people
will probably benefit and poor innocent
people will probably suffer yeah yeah
yeah yeah it is just anyway it's super
tragic and uh I know a lot of people
were asking us to to talk about and I'm
sure that we'll continue to I mean but
um I think it was important for us to
like take a moment and really digest
what was going on so we could be
thoughtful about it you know a lot of
people reach out hey you need to talk
about pal you need to talk about Israel
you need to show your support you need
to show your support and it's like what
they're really saying is you need to
Echo my feelings and that's not what we
have to do right we have to look at this
digest it and you know talk about it in
a way that we feel uh represents our
feelings on it and is most honest yeah I
think the thing we can all agree on is
that what's happening over there is
tragic yeah like the killing of innocent
people is horrible this is yeah on both
sides no justification for it yeah and
if we miss something don't kill us you
know we just want peace yeah 100% And I
hopefully
that yeah hopefully that will be uh [__]
man at this Mo at this point I'm like yo
just
ceasefires please please yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's so tricky so um yeah
hopefully you know hopefully uh we get
that and then we get you know some sort
of pause on this it feels like that's
the only thing that's been happening
over the last 70 years is just pause and
pause pause and
um but yeah at a certain point in
time at a c yeah at a certain point of
time something needs to something needs
to
happen I don't know what that is I don't
even know how you begin to solve a
situation like this yeah I don't think
we're going to we're going to solve it
right now yeah yeah well guys um that's
going to be the end of the Epis episode
uh thank you guys so much for tuning in
uh we appreciate you guys and uh yeah
hopefully hopefully we get some
resolution soon hopefully get some peace
soon and bare minimum hopefully we get
ceasefire soon so all these innocent
people's lives can uh cannot be taken
away God bless